on va débriefer tout de suite de cette
allocution avec vous thierry amouroux
affirmé à l'ap-hp porte parole du
syndicat infirmières sn pays qu'est ce
que vous retenez du propos du ministre
de la santé ce soir bien le la situation
est difficile par rapport à cette
deuxième vague parce que entre les deux
vagues et bien il ya eu des fermetures
de lits le temps dans les hôpitaux
il ya eu un certain nombre de départs de
soignants qui ont été choquée de la
façon dont ils ont fait l'objet d'une
maltraitance institutionnelle est il
donc on a aujourd'hui des soignants
fatigué de déjà du choc de la première
vague qui a été très très difficile pour
nous en terme de choix qu'il a fallu
faire part par manque de lits puis tout
l'été il a fallu essayer de d'élargir
les plages horaires pour prendre en
soins le plus possible de patients
chroniques qui avait été écarté pendant
trois mois deux de pique au lied et est
donc on est dans une phase difficile
pour aborder cette cette deuxième cette
deuxième vague
vous attendiez de nouvelles mesures de
restriction ce soir pour faire face
notamment la situation critique dans les
hôpitaux
oui oui clairement parce que pour nous
on voit bien le nombre de contaminations
liées au milieu scolaire qui représente
quand même 35 % des clusters et
l'identifier alors certes les jeunes
depuis six ans maintenant un masque
mais néanmoins on voit des enfants qui
s'entassent dans
i les couloirs dans les cantines
scolaires lorsqu'on voit qu'ils passent
des heures à 35 dans une classe alors
que d'autres pays comme l'allemagne ont
installé des appareils de qualificateur
d'air que l'italie ait l'idée plexiglas
entre chaque élève pour essayer de
ralentir
voilà on voit bien que au niveau
scolaire il ya un gros problème au
niveau des entreprises
1 c'est pareil même si on a accéléré un
peu l'été travail on n'impose pas on
pourrait faire beaucoup plus pour
sachant que 20% des clusters identifiés
ont lieu dans les entreprises
et puis troisième problème
cc transport bondée en particulier en
l'ile-de-france
même si on a un masque vous comprenez
bien que si vous êtes 150 dans un wagon
et bien c'est comme lorsque vous rentrez
avec un masque dans un compartiment su
meurt vous sentez tout toute la fumée
alors aujourd'hui par les chics par les
autorités sanitaires se sont notamment
les chiffres concernant la disponibilité
des lits en réanimation selon olivier
ferrand
aujourd'hui il ya centaines de personnes
sur 100 personnes contaminées il y en a
90 qui sont asymptomatiques 8% qui sont
hospitalisés 2% aujourd'hui qui
déclenche des formes graves de kovy 19
et qui sont admis en réanimation
c'est évidemment pour soulager ou en
tout cas éviter la saturation des
hôpitaux que sont prises
un certain nombre de restrictions
notamment le confinement annoncé il ya
une semaine
il faut aussi davantage de personnel
plus que des lits de réanimation
le ministre de la santé
a déclaré que 12000 personnel de
soignants s'était porté volontaire dans
votre établissement plus généralement
dans les hôpitaux aujourd'hui en france
comment est-ce que cela se
manifeste-t-il comment est ce qu'on les
forme comment est ce qu'on les a formés
les douze mille professionnels en
question ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas
spécialement de formation qui viennent
en renfort alors je sais pas si dedans
il ya les 8000 étudiants en soins
infirmiers
on a transformé en aide soignant qui au
passage sont quand même exploiter un
parce qu'on leur donne 1 euro 50 de
l'heure pour faire du travail ddt ex
régnant au niveau des formations en réa
la plupart des déformations ça a été
pour des au sein des chu souvent 14
heures de formation locale parfois des
tutoriels et c'est pas ça qui transforme
une infirmière en infirmière de
réanimation savoir qu' il faut compter
entre 6 mois 1 an d'expérience
professionnelle dans un service de
réanimation pour être vraiment
performante dans un service aussi lourd
est aussi technique et nous notre notre
souci c'est que entre les deux vagues
éviter des fermetures de lits donc on
est on se retrouve quand même diminué
par rapport à ça il n'y a pas eu
d'anticipation
on est le seul pays du monde qui est
continuer à fermer des lits en plein
période l'épidémie même si là on rouvre
des lits de réanimation éphémère pour
tenir compte du choc les leçons n'ont
pas été tirées et pour 2021
il est déjà prévu de fermer d'autres
milliers de
c'est ce qui est prévu je dois de
financement de la sécu pour 2021 merci
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions thierry amouroux infirmiers à
l'ap-hp porte parole du syndicat
infirmier sm pays